this is the best time in history a  grown-up by the way we can do whatever  we want  have you noticed grown-ups are having a  blast now and kids are miserable  it's all completely flipped when i was a  kid every grown-up was pissed off  defeated get off my lawn  now my friends are 42 all they do is  play video games read comic books and  watch pro wrestling  and every teenager i see now is obsessed  with politics and on medication  we won  it's all flipped look i'm 37 by the time  my dad was my age he had two kids a law  degree and owned a home i have  hulu  i'll ask my friend i'm like dude you're  44 you're gonna start a family he's like  what i live my mom i got a family  now let's eat these edibles and watch  the avengers i'm like all right let's do  it  that's adulthood now